here is how they start out they say
here's a quadratic okay
the clue they give you is go ahead like
you always do work out the sum and
product of roots and then they ask you
to make a new quadratic not this one a
new quadratic which has particular roots
that look a little bit different okay
so here's the way we're going to have a
go of this first let's work out the sum
and product in this case the sum of the
products is -2 and 3
there's the minus B on a and the product
of roots will be 7 over 3 ok now what
I'm going to ask you to do is forget
that this quadratic exists ok because I
want to make a new quadratic however I
do know that these things are true and I
have to hold on to these because the
question that's about to be posed to me
is in terms of alphas and [ __ ] not
just any other submitters it's these
alphas and betas okay so forget about
that old quadratic but just hold on to
this knowledge okay right now they want
us to create the first one is whatever
Part A or something like that
create a quadratic where it's roots are
not alpha and beta but Sri alpha and two
beta ok
now excuse me if I were to go through
the same kind of set of logic I would
say that the sum of roots is going to be
equal to but I don't have coefficients
to grab for that's because that's my job
to find out what the coefficients are so
I can't write this as minus B on a
because I don't know what B and a are
equal to but I don't need to because a
silent product of roots just come from
these guys right if that's one of the
roots and this is the other one the sum
of the roots will be su alpha plus 2
beta do you agree that's that's the sum
of the roots literally I just added them
up ok now here's why it was important to
hold on to these just like before
this is Lego right that can be built
from these pieces yes so all I have to
do is factor out that 2 like so and I
know what alpha plus beta is it's right
up there you told me what it was
so therefore
I get this result okay now remember I
said she said before I couldn't work out
the sum product of roots from - beyond a
because I didn't know what being a were
that's the question well now I know what
- beyond a is this is - be on a this is
what it's equal to for my new quadratic
does that make sense so just file that
away in your mind I've done the sum the
natural next step is to do the product
now ordinarily like I didn't start of
the question I work out the product of
roots by saying C on a but are you sick
of me saying this yet I can't do that
cuz I don't know what's in a are equal
to so therefore I've got to appeal to
something else namely if this is what
the root are and the product of the
roots is this times this okay with that
and I know what this is
two times two is and there's my alpha
beta hanging at the end and I know what
this is equal to that's alpha beta so
this is for alpha beta and for my new
quadratic equation C on a is equal to
this does that make sense so you can see
it's not that crazy of a leap to say
well it looks like a it's probably going
to be three yeah do you see how it
appears in the same spot and in the same
way I can say I think that looks like B
and I think that one color I think that
this looks like C is that okay you see
how I've compared all my numbers so
therefore my conclusion is there's a x
squared plus BX plus C this is my new
quadratic okay are you happy with that
do you see how I use the knowledge from
the original quadratic and then promptly
forgot about it because I was making a
new quadratic does that make sense I
just took the the pieces that I needed
and left behind the rest here's my new
quadratic
before I show you the other method which
is quicker but it's a little bit at the
moment it's a little bit black magic is
anyone have any questions about this
does it make sense
so okay yep
well slow down some of the routes is -
what yep and the product yep okay
so this is - be on a and this is C on a
yeah so you can do this whichever way
you like just as suggestion for you I
like to keep things integer as much as
possible so I would probably rewrite the
minus six wait did you say minus six on
three which is minus two okay I would
probably write that and get a common
denominator right which is which is nine
so I would probably write this is what
would this be minus 18 on nine right
because now you can see oh look the A's
look the same to me so I will make a 90
they're both whole numbers then these
would be the series and these have been
the B's make sense okay get ready for
some black magic now I'm just gonna
present this result this method rather
I'm not going to encourage you to use it
as your main result but I don't mind you
having it as kind of like a backup sort
of like when you use des mots to check
if your graph looks good or use a
calculator check if your algebraic
solution is valid watch this okay
remember how I asked you to forget about
the original equation the original one
let's remember it the original quadratic
was 3x squared
was it pasta X plus 7 do you agree okay
now just put your pens down for a minute
because if you blink you'll miss it
okay I'm going to create a new quadratic
off of this but just watch the way that
I do it see how the roots here are
exactly double what they were in the
first place do you agree it's double so
I'm going to compensate for that
doubling
by having watch carefully
it's that okay just gonna crunch some
numbers out make it a little simpler is
that all right yeah now what was this
original quadratic equal to I rubbed it
off it's under question this thing was
equal to zero
was it not equal to zero so if this is
now equal to 0 this is my new quadratic
right they asked for integer solutions
integer solutions right so how do I
what's stopping me from making this
integer this just is just this guy isn't
it so I should multiply through by ha
like I said I'm just going to let that
sit there for a moment the proper use of
this technique comes in actually not
extension one but extension two so they
get questions like this and they're so
like the way that it's phrased and the
particular kinds of combinations that
are given to you make this process here
impractical so you have to go through
this I'm not going to explain it to
everyone because the reason it's in
extension too is it's a bit it's a bit
brain bending okay but I think you guys
have enough sort of pieces in your mind
and enough knew how to work out to
reverse-engineer why does this work why
does this think about it
give you this okay